it is really hard as a gender
non-conforming person of color quasi
amputee with rickets to find somebody to
talk to who will listen to me speak my
truth did I just hear somebody laughing
on that hole you have my ass on speaker
no welcome to das para espanol oprima el
dos thank you for contacting us my name
is how can I help you today
Oh okay thank thank the Lord you've
answered I would like to file a
complaint
gosh I should ask I'm sorry how are you
today I'm wonderful how are you doing I
have been better like I said I would
like to lodge a complaint if you please
yeah are you the representative I would
speak with because I want to talk with
someone who can make a change over there
at Dove I don't want it to just go to
some you know folks who just send it on
to the higher-ups um
I don't have the authority to give you
any one hires but I can absolutely take
note of your comment and it does get
passed along that is sort of the chain
of commands here okay well I am calling
regarding your real beauty campaign you
wear your real beauty campaign about
body positivity yeah and I really
appreciate that
okay I'm gonna let you I want to say at
first I appreciate y'all doing that work
I appreciate that you want to represent
people with different people non
non-binary x' okay non-binary smen and
women and and people from different
cultures different races different body
types because I get it that's hard right
but I still I do not I myself am not
represented at all by this campaign and
I am frankly offended that people of my
ilk have been left out I'm just sorry
here that's confirm your calling because
the real beauty campaign you still feel
excluded from absolutely let me tell
y'all I am a real beauty I'm saying I
think y'all have a blind spot
because I am a non-agenda non-conforming
person of color you see that in the
campaign no you don't you don't see that
in the campaign and that guess what is
that does that mean
I'm not a real beauty though no and a
gender non-conforming person of color
okz of color and and I'm a quasi amputee
I don't see that in the campaign
is that in the campaign you got any
quasi quasi amputees in the campaign no
no how about folks with rickets
I also have rickets I have four rickets
so let me tell you let me tell you my
name is my name is Jessie okay Jess '
I'm telling you what I see when I see
that campaign is we want all we want
people of all body types - you're Doug
as long as people out there part of a
demographic they're gonna buy a soul
there's enough people right we got we
got skinny people we got fat people we
got black people we got lesbians right
we got gays but we don't have a
combination of a non-conforming person
of color quasi amputee with rickets I
apologize for that
you do feel excluded by that and I can
absolutely empathize oh I know you
apologizing and listen I know I know you
get people to just be pissed off calling
the other time so I don't want to come
down on you I don't wanna come down
y'all right cuz I understand like it's
not your fault but that's what I want to
talk to somebody who can make a change
because I know you got to apologize but
oh you know I wanna ask you how you how
do you feel how do you feel when you
hear that do you think do you do you
feel good about that that I'm not
representing that campaign you know I
can definitely empathize with how it
emphasized on some place obviously I've
never been any issue so that is not
something that I could feel but I tell
me I'm sorry and I can't imagine how it
goes figure I'm sorry it feels you know
what it feels like it feels like I live
in death it feels like I'm alive but I'm
dead at the same time because it's like
I might as well be dead because they
nobody recognized
in my existence and I don't know why you
know listen you get Pat's on the back
from other white people up there
Williamsburg pushing black folk out and
they talking about how they all
progressive issue and then you got
someone like me how do I listen I am a I
am a non-conforming person of color
we already listen you can cross you
cross that off the list we don't even
get to cross an amputee in rickets let
alone single income household I'm a
single mom right now I don't see that in
there
you know else I don't see y'all have
interviews what's your models let me
look into that for you
I can already answer the question it's
not your fault but no no we talking
about all different kinds of beauty I'm
just supposed to looking to be like oh
that's a that's a that's a fat white
[ __ ] I'm supposed to think that person
is good look but I don't know nothing
about them I want to hear what that
black woman there that black woman I
want to hear what she has to say I won't
hear what she has to say why she using
does what made her want to do the
campaign for duck you telling me oh
everybody's beautiful but we all
supposed to have self-confidence and
it's all well and good but I'm just
supposed to look at their bodies and
their bodies they represented you know I
represent about me but is that a white
and black but they all people they ain't
got no they ain't got no gender
non-conforming people of color
they all got legs or - what can y'all do
about this who do I gotta talk to to
make a change cuz I get it y'all
progressives but it seems like y'all
progressive in a way that's maybe
comfortable and what I'm doing right now
I hope you understand what I'm doing I'm
just trying to make sure that you are
all little and not you cuz it sounds to
me like you you cooled it sounds to me
like you understand where I'm coming
from but I want to make dove just a
little bit uncomfortable so y'all can
feel the pain that I feel every day as a
gender non-conforming person of color
who is a quasi amputee with rickets in a
second income household what we got to
do what I can do is forward your
comments to the brand if you'd like I
can take down their contact information
in case they're inclined for contacting
you sorry I'm trying to
type as I talk but I is that a joke
about my closet because you I know you
didn't just make a joke about the fact
that I can't type at all I was no that's
not all I genuinely apologize I was
being genuine and that I was apology
accepted but don't let me catch you
doing again
who's that can I get a name can I get a
name when I got his people to supervise
because I appreciate that you empathize
but I want to make sure that the people
there who making decisions who's going
out and putting this putting this up
there and cosmopolitan in a land that
they hear from me literally so you do
want to speak as a supervisor
yeah if that's gonna make a change I'm
just calling trying to make a change we
are to change we see I like you if you
don't mind I'm gonna place you on a
brief hold when I reach out to my
supervisor and see who's available take
a call
[Applause]
good afternoon thank you for calling
death my name is one of the supervisors
is this Jesse hi this is Jesse alright
Jesse I understand you were calling in
today regarding the the real beauty
campaign yes can I say ma'am yes ma'am
yeah yes ma'am I mean I spoke and I
spoke word and I gotta tell you it was
great it was very helpful okay I know
that y'all deal with people on customer
service all the time calling in pissed I
get it's not your fault but it is really
hard as a gender non-conforming person
of color quasi amputee with rickets to
find somebody to talk to who will listen
to me speak my truth okay
well I certainly understand and this is
in regards to the campaign that you saw
and and where did you see that
advertisement that's the problem it's
like you know one of those you know one
of those paintings that has like the
eyes that a little bit further back than
the rest of the paintings when you move
the eyes are following you in it's like
that everywhere I go it's on YouTube I
go to buy some clothes it's showing up
in my auto ads I see I saw it on the
subway I see the real beauty ads anyway
here's the thing here's the thing okay
I appreciate the concept I think the
idea of a real of real beauty is great
you got people of all different shapes
and sizes that's fantastic I don't see I
look at all of them women and people and
not but I don't see my face I don't see
myself represented at all and I want to
know what does thinks that it's okay to
exclude people of my ilk
if y'all real bitter campaign when I am
I don't know don't let out nobody tell
you different I am a real beauty let me
ask you this when you look at that
campaign if you can bring it up right
now what do you see what kind of people
do you see no I certainly understand and
I'm so sorry that you may not have been
represented what I you think it's a may
I'm telling you that is proactive I'm
telling you listen it's not just dull
it's everybody I don't see anybody
anytime I go and see a commercial I go
to
I got a water burger I go down to Carl's
jr. Burger King I don't see nobody like
me at anything campaigns and then I hear
dump doing a real beauty campaign it's
gonna be including people of all
different shapes and sizes of races I
started think things are looking up for
Jesse and then I to it it's the same
stuff it's the same that I see what's
every other campaign that's why I'm most
upset about this because I'm talking
about
I will game I'm a small business owner
it's what we call opportunity cost
opportunity cause because this was this
was a moment with someone like me to
shine and we ain't even included and I
absolutely did I just hear somebody
laughing on that hole you have my
[ __ ] speaker no there was not I'm
sorry around me but I'm sorry now
there's nothing funny about this because
I live in this every day it's not now
some more detergent okay I live every
day as a gender non-conforming person of
color quasi amputee with rickets single
income household I'm a single mother and
he does something else I was asking I
was asking I want to know about these
people I don't want you to see their
bodies it's like dog saying hey hey hey
everybody motive their bodies we're
looking in a beauty do you have any
interviews with their people what are
their likes what are their hobbies are
they remember of the Rotary Club what do
they do I have no idea I'm just looking
at a bunch of white bodies and since
black women and dove cause that progress
is that what you think is progress
you think that's inclusive no I
understand your concern absolutely and I
appreciate your comments and I'm
absolutely going to forward those to the
brand si who do you have do you another
one of your department who might be able
to share my pain who might be able to
relate with my struggle do you have
anybody in your department who is gender
non-conforming dangle wickets I know I I
do not I'm sorry
how many Wikus you have Annette Office
that's information that I don't have I
apologize but I'm more than
you can tell is the eyeball test it's
just an eyeball test it ain't that hard
to figure out you wouldn't know if
you've seen someone with rickets you've
seen somebody walking around like like
Doc Holliday like he go on out west for
tuberculosis well I'm very sorry Jessie
I'm not familiar with it
so I don't know much about it you know
what I I do not but that doesn't mean I
don't care about the situation send that
up and I want to see in that next
campaign from Doug I want to see from
dove someone like me
Matt called me I am available Jeff ' II
you can call me back you got a you got a
pencil there you got a pen you can write
with I can absolutely take down your
information here I'm sorry you said that
Jake is apostrophe II yes sometimes I
use a semicolon okay okay and you can
call me back and know I must have cut
out them okay sorry is there a last name
that I can apply to this as well no it
is just just apostrophe e I went through
a lot of work to get that my driver's
license I don't need a last name all
right not a problem at all all right
I'll absolutely forward this information
along you go ahead and you do that you
tell them it just possibly is available
and not only not only for Beauty shots
but I'm available for an interview to
speak to the transgender gender
non-conforming people of color quaza
amputee with rickets single mother
community at large
there's a lot of us out there now all
right absolutely I can do that for you
all right I appreciate it and see people
add of maybe you think we fighting I
think we're finally talking
talk to you later you haven't I'm
waiting for that call well thank you so
much for your time today Jesse and you
know we had a good phone call now I
gotta ruin it by sitting there laughing
laughing like a cyst like a cyst woman
and by the way I think I can hear from
your voice that you are white this woman
lesson and a woman of color gender
nonconforming quasi fut single income
household with rickets and not at all
just me I was so sorry if you took it
that way I certainly did not mean
anything at all I'm actually kind of
confused a little bit so I'm just
apologize for any confusion what
confusion because I I just apologize
because I was not laughing at you in any
any way and I'm so sorry if you thought
that yeah I did think that it sounded
like it it sounded like it no no I'm
very very sorry that you you may have
assumed that not happy I don't know if
maybe you may have heard somebody in the
background having a conversation with
someone else but I just I can listen I
can hear you Jesse Jackson I just wanna
make sure that you don't find my
condition funny and that you're taking
it seriously and it's gonna go in some
suggestion box with a bunch of other
angry white women saying aw 77 cents on
the dollar and I wanted to go to someone
who really understands the community
that I represent gender non-conforming
people of color quasi amputees single
income household with rickets no I
absolutely do understand in our black
people ez was like you know Jesus was
black did you know that's enough it's
bad enough that I got a look at posters
and paintings all over the place
with Jesus looking like he just came out
of a an SS catalog and blond hair
and in blue eyes Jesus was black oh I
like to go back to data alright does he
think it's like you know the drill just
click one of these other videos in a box
playing up here and I mean by there's an
actual box I don't of course mean that
in the feminine it's a slur but that of
course I don't mean box because men can
have boxes too and I don't mean to say
box I just that men can there's like a
DC outlet an AC outlet and they can be
either one that they choose depending on
the electrical current or fats charge of
ions I think